hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday and if not it's bent
Larsen to the rescue like my previous
two videos this game was also played in
1969 it was an organized chess match
between bent Larsen and a finish
Grand Master hake he was tearing in
although he did get his Grandmaster
title in 1975 this game was played in
1969 so he was still an international
master the match sure was consisted of
eight games bent Larsen won six games
and mister of astern and won two games
and this is one of the games they played
this is a game from Round seven bent
Larsen has the white pieces and it's
quite an interesting game Larsen plays
Knight to f3
we have Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3
and Bishop to g7 so in English opening
efore d6 and Larsen plays d4 transposing
into the Kings Indian defense we have
castles Bishop to g5 enough C's 5v5
gaining more space in the center and 92
a6 mr. Western ian is going for 96-97
and then if white allows it push a 6 and
b5 to get some expansion on the Queen
side although this is rarely rarely
possible if white decides not to let
black do this we have h3 not allowing
any Bishop g4 ideas now Knight to c7
black continues with his plan Bishop to
d3 a6 and the black is definitely ready
to put be five but Larson doesn't allow
it he put place a four we have Bishop to
d7 adding even more pressure to be five
but Larsen plays a5 completely not
allowing black and in b5 ideas and if he
does play it he will capture on poisson
we have worked the b8 and black is
persistent to do this he will put b5 but
well it's it's rather known that this
this kind of position always favors
white as this isolated a pawn will not
be a strength rather it will be a
weakness so we have castles by Larson
and b5
Larsson captures Amazon a capture some
v6 we have recapture some v6 and now
look the b1 and now Larson is ready to
push before if needed he 5 and nice the
e1 by Larson and some of the people
asked me in the comment section
why do some players play play a piece
back isn't it always better to play the
piece forward
well this knight on f3 pretty much did
all it could from f3 white definitely if
he wants to continue some sort of a king
sized attack or some sort of a king set
expansion he has to push f4 and he can't
really do this while the knight is an f3
so Larson's idea is Knight 2 e1
he will then Riemann over this Knight 2
D 3 when the bishop moves and the night
will from d3 be pressuring f4 so then f4
will definitely be possible so this is
Larson's idea Queen to e7
we have Bishop the c2 Larson continue
continues with its plan h6 attacking the
bishop and the bishop to e3 of course
Larson doesn't want to give up his dark
square bishop for this night and f6 and
the bishop will now also be supporting
f4 when Larson plays it also if Larson
decides to push b4 now the C pawn is
pinned so it can't capture on before
because it's pinned and Larson would
grab this rook
so if Larson does play before mr.
Steadman will have to play rook capture
some before if he wants to capture night
to h7 now black also wants to expand and
he's preparing f5 we have night to d3
Larson accomplished this plan of Riemann
hoovering the knight to d3 and Larson is
now definitely ready to push f4 we have
f5 and Larson responds with f4 we have a
captures on f4 and Knight captures on f4
and Larson is now threatening Knight
captures on g6 forking the Queen and the
rook so we have Queen to e8 now
defending g6 and Queen to d2 adding more
pressure to this h6 pawn after the
knight moves g5 stopping ideas like that
we have Knight back to d3
and now f4 bishop to f2 is played and
now it's time for black to strike and he
does he plays f3 destroying Wyatt's
defenses we have E 5 by Larson and now F
captures on g2 King captures on g2 and
this is a very nice moment in the game
which should be definitely analyzed in
this position while this position is
completely drawn and if Blackwood if
black desires he can draw this instantly
with a move like Bishop captures on h3
with check if the King moves of course
Larson loses the rook so the bishop has
to be accepted and after King captures
on h3 Queen to h5 forces a perpetual
check King G to Queen f3 check King back
to the H file Queen h5 check King G to
Queen f3 and well white maybe could
refuse a perpetual with a move like for
example if King goes to G 1 then Queen
to g4 but he would have to give up his
his own dark square Bishop so the game
could continue but this would this this
would be a very doubled edge game so mr.
Westerland decides not to go for this
and after King to g2 he lunges his queen
into the attack with Queen to h5 and now
it's it's it's anyone's game we have
Queen to e3 because Westermann was
threatening to capture on h3 and also
Queen to f3 check was a threat so Queen
- III stops both of these threats we
have na dhih captures on e5 and this was
this was a mistake and mr. Westerland
sparked moves like Bishop captures on e5
would have been better although this
does require you to give up your dark
square Bishop and this is something our
King's Indian player never wants to do
other idea was playing a move like g4 to
continue the attack but okay he decided
to go for D captures on e5 and Larson
plays and Knight captures on c5 we have
Bishop to c8
now controlling this this night as this
is a
a famous relationship between a bishop
and the knight the bishop is covering
all of the squares that the knight can
jump to we have Queen to D 3 and now
Larson is threatening Queen captures on
h7 so this has that we stopped the
Bishop to a5 is played
we have Knight to e4 and rook to g6 and
this allows Larson to play Bishop to c5
and now well this is a very unpleasant
position for mr. Astaire Ihnen as if he
doesn't want to keep his rook on an on
DF file which he pretty much has to as
it's the only piece defending this
Bishop on a5 it's impossible for him to
play a move like rook to f7 Knight
discovering f6 because rook captures on
f5 and after rook captures an f5 night
to g3 and now forking the Queen and the
rook and there is no way this Queen can
protect this rook so unfortunately black
is losing a whole rook here
so after Bishop to c5 mr. best Iranian
who was who was a player known for his
originality and combinations played g4
he invites Larson to capture the rock on
f8 and Larson does he is not afraid of
of the of the coming attack Bishop
captures on f8 and now G captures on h3
with with a double check from the pawn
and the rook Larson plays King to h1 and
we have Knight captures Bishop on f8 and
Queen to f3 a Larson is up the exchange
and he would well very much like to
exchange Queens here and it's not that
easy to decline this as Queen captures
on f5 is also a threat so there is only
one move that that stops the exchange of
Queens and also saves this Bishop and
this is what the finish international
master goes for he plays Bishop to g4
and now attacking the Queen and he
allows this [ __ ] Queen to f7 check
because he doesn't see what Larson could
actually do from there but well it's
important that the Larson sees it and he
does Larson plays Queen to f7 would
check came to h8 and now how do you
continue this attack with white
while Larson finds a very interesting
way he plays Queen captures on f8 with
check sacrificing a queen and of course
you do have to accept the Queen Bishop
captures on f8 and now rook captures on
f8 with check and this is the problem
you can't block the the check with the
rook if rook to g8 and rook captures and
g18 captures NGH and Knight to f6
picking up the Queen and h5 and also
winning the game so after rook to f8
with check mr. Westerland played Queen
King to g8 and Larsson now plays rugby
to f1 with the threat of rook to f7
checkmate the most resilient way to
defend this would be something like rook
to b6 creating an escape route for a
king on g6 but this is placing the king
you know right in front of this Bishop
like decides not to go for this so in
this position after rook b2 f1 he played
Bishop to e6 mr. Annan decides to give
up this piece to exchange one of the
rooks and it seems like he managed to
defend but Larson finds finds a great
poison in his position D captures on e6
was played and not rook to g1 rook
captures on g1 and now King captures
rook on f8 and it certainly seems like
black managed to defend this he does
have a queen and the night and he does
have a very dangerous pawn on h3 but
Larsen has one move that completely
destroys all of blacks hopes he plays
rook the rook to f1
although rook the g8 was also possible
but this required some extra calculation
calculations if you captured the rock of
course 92f six wins the Queen and the
game and well he had to decide what to
do after King goes to e7 but he decided
not to go for this after King to f8 he
played rook to f1 check and here it's a
very very hard for the black king to
decide what to do if you play more like
King to e8 you get Knight to f6 with the
Royal fork you lose the Queen
if you play a move like King to g8 you
also get Knight to f6 with the Royal
form well if you play em like King to g7
you get e 7 now and this is a beautiful
position as wherever whatever black
plays he is lost either he's losing the
queen or the pawn is getting promoted
either way it's it's a very unpleasant
position for example Queen to e8 if
black decides to block this pawn then
rub the g1 check King to f7 and now
Knight to d6 again picks up the Queen so
a very unpleasant position for for
Western and after this rook to f1 check
and he decided to go for the only square
that doesn't allow white to win the game
immediately he played King to e7 and
here we have Knight to d5 with Czech
Knight captures on d5 d captures sorry C
captures on d5 and in this position mr.
mr. Annan resigned the game as the
position is too powerful for Larson
disconnected passed pawns the D and E
pawn are ready to launch forward and if
you try and defend this for example with
a more like Queen to g6 simply v6 with
check the pawns are marching and if King
captures a night to see if I would check
Bishop wins the Queen and after C
capture Sun d5 you play something else
for example Queen to h4 then rook to f7
check King wherever it goes you simply
play King to h2 first and not allowing
any Queen to e1 checks and now while
black has to play something if Queen to
g4 then e 7 check King to e8 and now
Knight to f6 again with the Royal fork
but after King captures you don't you
don't have to grab the Queen
you can simply promote your pawn to
Queen and after King captures knight on
f6 you have a queen and the bishop and
an easily won game so yeah after this
seek after Sun d5 his turn and had
enough of this game
and he resigned like I said he was an
international master he did witness in a
grand master title in 1975 and he won
the Finnish championship four times so
so definitely definitely a strong player
but in the end the Larson won the match
with a score of six to do so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it a nice
Larson game I didn't feature that many
Larsson games on my channel so far I
would like to thank Justin fish
Miha risky and an unknown person who
contributed through Bitcoin on my
channel thank a lot I really appreciate
it
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon